Russell Crowe not a strong singer you
ever see lame is oh yeah sang like a
bird he was terrible is in a band he's
not good at singing lame is what about
his band yeah I mean I don't know
anything about his band no but I saw
ladies and the Russell whoa
I suddenly mean like Anne Hathaway I
should have been in that to play in
Hathaway like Russell Crowe's role oh
I'm telling you I saw a job fair on
Broadway yes and he could sing like an
angel job fair in the movie played by
Russell Crowe terrible fact that you've
seen that twice really makes me hate you
I've seen the movie a ton of time thanks
I went to see lame is this is like in
1996 I was on a double date me Darryl
hammered a couple of girls at the time
so our girlfriends and I go to see it
and at the beginning Garret else does
mouthing some words I go to the overture
hello have you seen this before he goes
17 times
lame is is so good dude it's not see it
like 50 times it's not good you just go
with him I've seen part of it it's the
best musical there's ever been so what I
don't think it's the best ever I think
it's I think it's one of the best I
think Westside stories up they would its
[ __ ] Harley I don't got a bad so
that's a good or bad like you say right
to bring that one up I I you know I just
suck it up cuz he wants a good review
what stay cool boy stay coy boy crazy
boy stay cool boy
go man go
what else musicals I like Oh what about
cabaret [ __ ] amazing music Wow Oh
cabaret actually would have worked with
the trans if Joel Grey was a transgender
yeah whatever yeah I still like lame it
stay cool let me hear a second of this
shit's about English is [ __ ] terrible
what it's [ __ ] terrible crazy
snapping their fingers oh this is 1961 I
don't care after to the 1800s lame its
lamé is yada yada Oh [ __ ] vu+ lame is
takes place around the time of the
French Revolution
oh and boy you know it's funny you
always hear the French Revolution me in
bed but you watch they measure like I
can understand it yeah yeah yeah you
know what it is about lame is you get
both sides yes you do you know what I
mean actually you don't get both sides
you get once I'm really good Javert sigh
back to ya know I'm watching this is
awful
when this isn't lame inside story it's
awful
oh just better know is great Book of
Mormon was it great news yeah it's funny
comedy the songs were great was good and
the songs were good but it was lame is
is great it's not great this is amazing
oh it's nice incredible he only likes
book a moment you know why cuz I've only
seen Book of Mormon he's never seen Wes
are you judging them based on Broadway
musical this cold contempt prior to
investigation no sorry you have contempt
prior to investigation no all I have it
at your eyes opening that why I didn't
say I did see some of lame is I tried to
watch it and I thought this stinks I
turned it off the opening song I like
and then look down I will show you
oh look at this snapping and dancing in
the parking garage
how am I wrong did not like this this is
[ __ ] awesome I think everything in
its time being Travis I've never seen
either well I saw a plate man now that's
what I call a mature answer I've never
seen either you're just he said I don't
descend smarter now what now what do you
think what you're watching right now and
this give it a chance
fine thank you give things a chance I am
it I gave it a chance you know what
hello Maria is a great song - more like
Blondie's Maria is great these gangs are
terrible you need some more shows is the
thing enough shows I don't like the
style of them I just saw hello again
what's up I just saw hello again it's
not a musical oh hello yeah it's good
funny it was funny I saw it yeah yeah
Jim's too busy at Amy's after-party too
I don't think we like Broadway shows
why'd you go to Broadway show and then
you know something talk about the
airport I just saw lame is have you
caught the new beautiful is not playing
anymore limas oh I went to the second to
last show the job it was fabulous house
cats I love cats ever I heard catch is
brutal can't you know what's great about
wicked have you seen that miss about
micro he's a comedian in the 80s and it
was very funny and he goes yeah
hey go to these Broadway shows they
never the Arizona cast I want to see
cats they're dogs
true this saw strong memories in cats is
like one of the best songs ever what's
the best soil aim is this is the last
saw come on I don't know there's a lot
of really good songs in lame is
probably on my own how about this wish I
was right now all right you know what
we'll end the show then how about that
yeah so you happy wheels for you happy
Collin and Sam's Broadway hour is coming
to it that's right when I come back home
we're gonna talk show - oh yeah we are
oh and I'll have them all lined up by
the way you know what we didn't get to
do today that we should do tomorrow oh
by the way another great show fiddler
but go ahead oh if only I've never seen
it but I've heard great things Jesus I'm
shaking your head why I remember seeing
fiddler on the roof for like my eighth
grade there's a reason why Travis
because his mom ran away with the Jewish
yeah that's true she came in one time
with shingle prints in her back she
never spoke to her in the vagina Oh No
Wow